ييل، ما مدى تفاؤلك بشأن هذه
الصفقة المفترضة، يجب أن أخبرك أنني لا أستطيع التأكد
حتى لا تتم الموافقة عليها فحسب، بل
في الطريق بالفعل، وحتى نتمكن
بالفعل من رؤية الأطفال الرضع والأمهات في
المنزل، فماذا حدث عندما أنت وأفراد
الأسرة الآخرين  التقيت
بالبرلمان الإسرائيلي، ما هو شعورك عندما
تعبر أخيرًا عن غضبك؟ مباشرة
إلى
المسؤولين الحكوميين، حسنًا، أستطيع أن أخبرك أن اجتماعي
في البرلمان كان مرهقًا للغاية
لأن بعض أعضاء البرلمان
الذين التقينا بهم لم يكونوا على اتصال على الإطلاق
بما كنا نحاول نقله وكانوا
في الواقع يحاولون الترويج
لعقوبة الإعدام في إسرائيل بينما
نحاول إعادة رهائننا إلى الوطن،
هذا ما ترونه الآن أم أن
هذا كان نقاشًا لا يصدق
بقيادة إيتار بينف  وزير يميني للغاية
هنا في إسرائيل وقد
عاملونا بطريقة فظيعة حقًا، لقد صرخوا
فينا، لقد صرخوا، أنت ترانا
نصرخ ولكن ذلك لأنهم صرخوا
علينا أولاً، كما تعلمون في إسرائيل،
العائلات والعائلات الحزينة
عادة ما يعتبر الرهائن مقدسين
بطريقة ما ولكن هنا قرروا فقط
استهدافنا ومعاملتنا كأسلحة
سياسية حتى تعلم أنني أعلم
أن إدارة الأمن القومي
احتضنتك بالفعل بعد أن طلبت منه
ألا يقول ماذا قلت في تلك المرحلة
ماذا
قال حسناً؟ لقد طلبت منه عدم طرح هذا
الأمر على طاولة النقاش،
يرجى إزالته فقط وتأجيله، لا
لا تتحدث عن
عقوبة الإعدام الآن بينما هناك رهائن
في أيدي حماس
منظمة إرهابية ونظر إلي
وقال أنا من حكومة الوفاق الوطني افعل ذلك على أي حال وبعد أن
أجرينا كل المناقشة بشكل جيد، لقد توسلت إليه للتو وأخبرته أنني
أخبرته أنني أتوسل إليك
تأجيل هذا ثم قام للتو
وقرر أنه سيذهب  ليذهب
ويعانقني وأخبرتهم أنني صعدت وأنا أعلم أنني
صعدت بنفسي وقلت له من فضلك من فضلك
لا تفعل هذا من فضلك
همست حتى يسمعني ولكني
لم أرغب في إذلاله قال  من فضلك
لا تفعل هذا، لقد فعل ذلك على أي حال، لقد
هاجمني بقوة أكبر وقبلني على
رأسي ثم نشر
الصورة على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وكأنه
يعانق عائلات
الرهائن الذين لم أفعل ذلك.  أريد أن أقول
مهينًا لأنني أعتقد أنه من
المهين بالنسبة له أن يفعل شيئًا كهذا
لعائلات الرهائن ولشخص من
الواضح أنه لا يريد هذا التعاطف الزائف،
هذا التعاطف البلاستيكي منه، ما
نريد رؤيته ليس المزيد من الموت وليس
المزيد من الفراغ  تتحدث عن
عقوبة الإعدام ولكن من الواضح أن
العكس هو الصحيح وهو رؤية
عودة الحياة من غزة إلى إسرائيل.
أفهم أنك تلقيت رسائل نصية من
أشخاص يزعمون أنهم يعرفون ابنة عمك
كارميلا، لا بأس، لماذا
ماتت هذه الرسائل وهل تعرف من؟
أرسلتهم على وجه التحديد،
نعم حسنًا، لقد حصلت عليه الأول
قبل بضعة أسابيع ثم كان هناك
واحد آخر قبل أربعة أو خمسة أيام، لقد تم
بناؤهم بنفس الطريقة التي يقولون بها مرحبًا، هل هذا أحد
أقارب كاريل جات وأقول نعم
ثم هم
بدأت محادثة WhatsApp uh بالقول نعم
إنها بخير، إنها تتمتع بصحة جيدة وهي في
أيدٍ أمينة يمكنني أن أؤكد لك ولكني أريدك
أن تعرف أننا نعاني من نقص في
بعض الأشياء وقد تتأذى